hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report let's find out what's happening
in the world with Stacy max you know in
the last episode you mentioned that
bankers didn't go to jail okay and I
want to pick up on that theme because it
is quite an important story to think
about well you know we've been covering
this sort of demise of the US Empire and
you know of course there's nothing out
of the ordinary every every single
Empire eventually collapses partly for
the same reasons but one thing that
always enters the space is corruption
and the pie begins to shrink and the
viciousness for the various powerful
families and names and people you know
in the system start to fight viciously
for control of that shrinking pie and I
think we see that with with what
happened to Paul Manafort when he was
found guilty in the two federal charges
and two federal cases and then the state
of blue states of the very democratic
state of New York decided that they're
also going to try him for mortgage fraud
and and they've gone after him hard and
they're vowing that we're going to be
vicious and violent and aggressive and
vindictive with you so it really made me
think of these sort of corrupt systems
that we're gonna see because obviously
then a red state is gonna start to fight
back and maliciously and capriciously
target somebody well-known in the
Democratic Party and of course New York
in particular that the audacity of this
I want to point out that as you and I
have covered the mortgage fraud crisis
of 2007 through 2009 that collapse of
the global economy of course happened
because of wide spread mortgage fraud in
the United States not only on the origin
ation of these mortgages that the likes
of Wells Fargo and Wachovia were pushing
but the packaging of those bad debts up
by the likes of goldman sachs for
example and then sold to pension funds
and even though they knew them to be
sacks of bleep
a reminder that new york erickson
the Attorney General at the time he led
to this headline New York to get 670
million from mortgage settlement this
was from April 2016 on USA Today a five
billion dollar settlement Monday by the
Justice Department with goldman sachs
over the mortgage crisis in 2008
includes six hundred and seventy million
dollars for New York Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman said the piece for New
York includes four hundred and eighty
million dollars for consumer relief and
a hundred and ninety million in cash
justice delayed is justice denied
right so they just play out the game
play out the clock and by the time they
award the fine it's already been paid
for our three or four times in the
washing machine that is Wall Street or
goldman sachs so yeah it's corrupt I
mean corruption is you see this end of
empire because actually the thing about
money is that it makes you more insecure
not more secure and so as you become
more insecure with greater wealth you
become more paranoid and you begin to
act out and you begin to try to destroy
your enemies and so leads to this
insular type of thinking and it leads
toward an empire like the u.s. now
trying to draw up the drawbridge
particularly and we've made this point
before after 9/11 the wealthy in America
decided we're not playing anymore we're
going to just grab as much as we can of
the cash out there in the system and put
it you know offshore that's why there's
now twenty two trillion offshore and so
their amount of credit in the system
shrunk the central bank instead of
punishing the bank's just flooded the
system with more of the fiat money and
then those who are the paranoid have
yachts versus the have-nots decided you
know we're gonna put that more offshore
so they just keep printing and shipping
it offshore and it's completely
bypassing the economy and so the economy
is getting more starved for credit and
the people are getting more restless and
you couldn't do your own research by the
way just go to google and look for the
data for the past twenty years or thirty
years and you'll see quite clearly from
2000 2001 which not only did 9/11 happen
but also Bill Clinton paved the way for
the wealth and income gap to happen for
that looting to happen with the
Commodities Futures Modernization Act
and the
the the destruction of glass-steagall so
all those things were in place and you
could see it you could see the plunder
happened live in the charts but I want
to move on to this other story about you
know the the college bribery scandal you
know it's a small-time thing as twenty
five million dollars or at least the
bits they've identified but there's one
person in particular that I want to
highlight that was arrested for bribing
hit you know the way in for his children
to one of these universities but it
brings up Bono and this notion of the
virtue signaling celebrities and they're
sort of capitalism they're sort of an
impact investing that is actually
covering up the basically the this
plunder system so I wrote our entire
system is one elaborate ruse to keep the
peasants from realizing that they live
in a neo feudal society and this was in
response to a tweet stream I'll read the
first one the juiciest most revealing
fact in the college bribery story isn't
the Hollywood celebrities it's a guy
named Bill who's alleged involvement
tells us everything we need to know
about our age what is alleged in the
scheme is that someone who claimed to be
working to change the system change
capitalism empowers others helps others
rise was working downstream to lock
others out of a slot they perhaps
deserved but that would said go to their
kids and now the absolute Dean's of the
doing well by doing good
industrial complex a man who embodied
the faith that the meek of the earth
could be saved by private equity barons
has been indicted for rigging the
opportunity against a disadvantage so
this is a guy from a private equity firm
called TPG and he and bono have a
segment at this private equity firm
called impact investing that these
wealthy oligarchs these billionaires
these guys who have received all the
free money that can tell in effect from
the Fed all these people who are the
losers and all these people who are the
winners you know the Friends of Hillary
Clinton and Bill Clinton that they with
their impact investing they can help the
poor around the world through their
investing they'll invest in these people
get a return but
they exclusively will be able to deal
with the situation so here's a guy who
was prancing around the world with Bono
saying you know we're gonna we're
billionaires and we're gonna help
everybody by you know through our
investment philosophy but behind the
scenes he was actually basically
undermining the whole system removing
the ladder for your children to get a
leg up by bribing his own children way
ahead of your own children right well
you mentioned Bono and you know of
course you see Bono showing up places
like Davos you know Davos is a annual
gathering where people reinforce their
virtue signaling while they pillage the
global economy this recent Davos there
was a guest who showed up who started to
point out that Davos was a fraud and
that they never talked about raising
taxes or anything that could actually
meaningfully help the people that they
say that they're helping and they that
guy was you know throwing you know a cat
amongst the pigeons you know I was like
oh what's this wake-up call then he
ended up on Tucker Carlson show and then
brought even more truth to that show and
then that segment was never aired so
that's the problem again with being
wealthy is that it breeds insecurity so
you have to go to these Davos events or
these other conf abs or get your kids
into school or Ivy League schools
because it if you don't eat begin to
kind of dwell on the fact that if the
very superficial fiat money that defines
you as your person is taken away you
have nothing left you're an empty shell
you're just a mechanism to to channel
this fiat nonsensical paper money
through to to to to keep those that are
in the business of this can't tell an
effect of getting the early benefits to
themselves in business so we have a
shrinking pie and there's a very huge
political civil wars going on Red Team
Blue team you know the red team is the
Republicans and they're nasty and they
don't mind being nasty there
they they're up front with it then
you've got the social justice warrior
side the blue team the Democrats
Hollywood The Wall Street and they all
do good they they give to charity all of
the celebrities that got caught out in
this scandal Felicity Huffman and Lori
Loughlin they gave hugely to charity to
charities that help disadvantaged
children and yet they themselves were
actually behind the scenes pulling the
stepladder away from anybody to be able
to even get onto the ladder in this case
this guy is pointing out that Bill
mccoshen who epitomizes the modern
fantasy that the rich people who rigged
the modern world who monopolized the
American dream for themselves are the
solution to regester
are in Justices and obviously bono is a
very huge friend of many of these
celebrities of all the billionaires and
all the presidents of the United States
and he gets to hang out with these
people and he gets to basically allocate
your taxpayer funds towards things that
will make him feel better about avoiding
all of his taxes for example in Ireland
he doesn't pay any taxes but he gets
basically the US State Department allows
him to be so wealthy through the US
State Department strong-arming everybody
in the world through trade deals and
basically patent and copyright
enforcement's that he gets huge monopoly
rights essentially that in the whole
creative space he's a monopolist he's a
predatory monopolist as is Bill Gates
that's why the Bill Gates and bono hang
out because they're both predatory
monopolists you know it's a variation on
the old theme of whitewashing you know
people understand what this phrase
whitewashing means but then we had green
washing where you pretend to be an
environmentalist while destroying the
environment like an Exxon or a Mobil
then he had blue washing where you
pretend to be doing something good with
the UN while you're doing something bad
like abusing kids overseas then you had
green mailing became variational
blackmailing you know corporate raiders
of the 1980s they have rebranded
themselves as activist investors right
so essentially you know it just comes
back to this idea of whitewashing you
know you're committing morally
questionable acts whether you're bono or
whomever
and but you can whitewash this in one
way or another through various schemes
and mechanisms you know it all starts
off with well-meaning people like
probably Bono feels like he's a really
good guy and he cares about people and
he probably gives a lot of money to
charity but the fact is like this system
as this guy's final tweet in his stream
points out is what is alleged in this
scheme is that someone this private
equity guy working with Bono who claimed
to be working to change the system
change capitalism empower others help
others rise was actually working
downstream to lock others out of a slot
that they perhaps deserve but that would
instead go to their kid you know this is
actually the whole system there are all
these side doors that are probably that
loud or somebody is shouting about you
know wanting to help others and do good
for others you know you can think of big
global churches or you know it the more
they're shouting about how good they are
and how much they care about poor people
and are helping people often it's just
covering their own guilt about opening
these side doors just for their own
security security yeah that's why I see
all these elaborate schemes for example
in serial killers you know they tried to
whitewash or to trade the context for
their murders you know yeah okay these
guys are morally corrupt and they're
bankrupting people and they're cutting
off access for at for a success for many
people but even to the level of an
actual no-goodnik like Paul Manafort the
fact is the New York Justice Department
basically enabled a much huger fraud
trillions of dollars in the mortgage
market back in 2007 they continued to
cover it up and now they get to throw
you one guy who they say they're going
to destroy and see their work they're
too tough on this crime yeah sounds like
a brazen con anyway we're gonna take a
break and when we come back much more
coming your way
[Music]
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to return to our
conversation with Carl denature of
market
- ticker dot-org Carl welcome back
thank you very much max by the way I
should mention that whenever people stop
in the street they say what do you have
in coral back on you know this is Carl
denature is our favorite guest anyway
let's get into it so the notion of mmt
modern monetary theory has swept much of
the american left recently first of all
what is it and then we'll get into what
you think of it but what is it supposed
to be I guess you could just call it
chart ilysm which is sort of what it is
which sounds an awful lot like charlatan
ISM and that's essentially which God
it's it's the premise that the amount of
currency and debt that you issue is of
no consequence to the economy that the
government essentially uses taxes to mop
up excess liquidity and not finance its
operations and the only penalty that you
will pay for using too much of this is a
higher inflation rate it's that they
leave that last part kind of in the
footnotes but that's where the real
problem comes from with it the thing
that doesn't make much sense to me is
that basically you're still relying on a
group of people at the center of this
kind of command and control mmt style of
doing business to somehow manage the
economy based on their their their their
their their kind of intellectual ability
but not but but not relying on market
signals so you're not using market
signals anymore you're using a group of
people's judgment and their subjective
judgment which is it's kind of like
worse than Keynesianism even it's like
Keynesianism but much worse Karl well
Keynesianism at its core was the premise
that during boom times you increased
taxes and you filled the coffers with
with money and then during busts you
used it to you use that surplus to try
to level out
the system the problem that Keynesianism
has is that human nature is that during
blooms you won't raise the taxes you
won't put away the money you'll
immediately spend it on various programs
because of course there's a bomb there's
no reason to save anything because
everything is going well it's all
swimming and then when things go bad
there's nothing to do it with so you add
more debt on so Keynesianism in practice
ends up being MNT but mmm tea is just a
flat-out fraud and the problem with it
is that it it puts forward the idea that
you can print value and that of course
is impossible you can't push a computer
button and emit cars or cause a surgeon
to operate on you and take out your
diseased gall bladder there isn't any
way to do that and so the premise that
you can somehow push a button and make
these things happen
as opposed to actual human labor making
them happen is nuts it kind of
repudiates the whole idea of modern
economics going back to you know Adam
Smith and the invisible hand and the
whole enlightenment as a matter of fact
so I would I would posit that you are
probably not a big fan of aoc and her
ideas but the question I wanted to ask
was you know can you blame Millennials
and the younger generation for wanting
to knock down the corrupt pyramid scheme
debt ponzi tilting walls from the young
to the old you know they the Millennials
they're getting the short end of the
stick the the baby boomers like myself
took it all ALC is holding out something
that they believe will be the the elixir
the cure of all of this so can you blame
them Karl well of course I can blame
them if you've got a massive pain in
your back and a drug pusher hands you a
bunch of pain pills and says you know
here this will fix your problem but you
weigh 450 pounds and you're eating five
bags of Doritos a day and and two and a
half cases of coke of going down your
piehole you know if you got rid of the
extra 250 pounds your your
probably wouldn't hurt so much so what
are we really playing with here we're
playing with people who have have a dis
dis con game that goes on throughout
millennia it is not just the Millennials
that do this it's been done dozens of
times over throughout human history
instead of actually looking at what's
happened and say okay the fraud and the
scams must stop somebody hands you a
cheap easy way out whether it's the drug
dealer around the corner or its AOC and
says here just take this it'll all be
fine
and that sounds attractive
it's especially attractive when you have
a very a try very physically attractive
young woman that's pushing this mantra
instead of evil old hag like Hillary
Clinton and so I'm not surprised that
it's taken off but it's going to it's
extraordinarily destructive you know
this mmt thing several years ago I was
on a segment with Lauren Lyster when she
she used to be on her team and we did
this with one of the proponents of this
this premise at the time she wanted me
to have an out one-on-one debate with
him and I did I don't remember the
gentleman's name but basically what I
did was I took a twin our bill on the
air tort half and said see I just
doubled you wealth now you have 220 and
the impact was instantaneous I mean you
know anybody that saw that be like wait
a minute no you did but see that's
that's the elixir that that AOC and
others are trying to offer here yeah
well done on that I remember the show
and it kind of shut down that debate
pretty quickly but you know what's
interesting is that ALC she's she was
debating in Congress recently took on an
executive from Wells Fargo Wells Fargo
she was asking trying to make a
connection are making the point that
about a pipeline causing some
environmental damage and saying you know
basically shouldn't Wells Fargo take
some responsibility for this and Wells
Fargo executive was pointing out that
you know they're not the managing the
pipeline they're just funding
this pipeline and you know they're not
they're not the person to talk to and
yet we if she dug a little deeper you
know and the question became remember
the Exxon Valdez when Blythe masters
invented the credit default swap but
exonerated them from that problem using
derivatives mr. banker isn't Wells Fargo
in effect and we can make the case you
fund the pipeline you don't taking
responsibility for it but you and we
know this from what's going on in the
industry and insulated yourself from
risk you're making a riskless bet a
riskless underwriting this pipeline and
it so in other words she's she could dig
one level deeper into the into the
rabbit hole and start to pick apart the
system a little bit you know she could
actually become dangerous Carl you're
assuming that she understands enough to
be able to do that I have a suspicion
she doesn't and is is essentially just
parroting things and on top of that
she's to be very careful where she goes
with that sort of a line of questioning
and thought because let's just say that
her or one of her protege x' you know
elizabeth warren or somebody like that
wins presidency in 2020 and starts
putting some of these policies in place
and they bankrupt and killed 50 million
americans does she hang on the National
Mall at noon for promoting the policies
that the killed 50 million Americans i
buy that same sort of derivative
standard I think she gets a date with
the gallows okay well you know I'm
always willing to talk about the gallows
you know it's always an interesting
conversation but we got to move on so
what what if you were at giving them
advice exactly what could we tell them
you know those Millennials you know what
can we give them tell them like how to
fix this I mean I got some ideas McCarl
what would you say you have to stop the
medical scam for starters that's the
very first thing because that's 20% of
the economy right now it's 1.5 and it's
going to bankrupt the nation within the
next six years if we don't stop this
when it becomes exposed the government's
funding model is going to be severely
disrupted and there is a risk it may
collapse
now either way you're going to see
extraordinary increases in cost of
living across the board applied to
everybody and the people that are going
to get hurt the worst other people that
have the least that's just the way it
works so that needs to stop and it needs
to stop now and then the other thing
that we need to do is we need to take a
very close look at this so-called click
through consent model that we have with
essentially everything today and that
needs to go away and I've got some
thoughts on that and some stuff that I'm
working on it's difficult to craft in
such a way that it doesn't become
unamerican really but at the same time
the idea that essentially these
extraction based business models are all
that's left and we need to put a cork in
that because true innovation gets
crowded out by bad investment and if we
don't find a way to make innovation
worthwhile real innovation we're not
gonna have any and then productivity is
is what drives the world in the end
right so if I click through consent
you're talking about it's they're very
easy to click the terms of consent you
agree to the terms of T and C of the of
this model and within that myriad legal
document essentially you're giving away
a lot of rights and you you're imposing
this draconian feudal layer into the
economy we've got about two minutes left
the New York is going after lobbyist
Paul Manafort for mortgage fraud you
covered the role of banks and
industrial-scale robo-signing and other
mortgage fraud back in 2008 Carl tell us
about the role of New York and giving
copper to the big banks for their
trillions of dollars of crimes
well Paul Manafort is going to prison
and is going to probably go to prison
again under New York's law because he
was an associate of Donald Trump's there
the number of people who pulled
something at least as equally egregious
as what he did in the mortgage market
and got away with it not just in 2008
and just prior to that but all the way
to today it is literally without ability
to count so you've got one guy that gets
busted and and you know then the state
of New York sees that well you know he
get along enough sentence the way we
kind of see things at the federal level
so let's charge him as a state
prosecutor with a state crime that sort
of thing is very Orwellian it's nasty
and we as a body politic it better put a
stop to that because if not that could
be used against anybody so we're
entering into a period now where these
big platforms like as you point out the
click consent model getting back to this
monopoly discussion we're having you
know they're abusing their power this is
an abuse of power and they are becoming
political booth Hammett's and so either
you use posit you say let's just enforce
the law against these big tech companies
you don't need to break them up but
we're going to enforce that law Karl it
seems like the entire system is corrupt
how did how do we go about enforcing it
we've got about 15 seconds I don't see
anywhere right now unless the people in
this country rise up and demand it and
are willing to enforce that but it's
gonna happen because there's just no
impetus on either side of the aisle to
actually go stop do it so this 2020
election coming up
it looks like the Democrats are don't
have much traction anybody on that side
that looks interesting to you Karl
no and that's that's a shame because
real competition is something that we
ought to have in elections oh yeah I
would think so I totally agree well
thanks so much being a once again on the
Kaiser report Karl Denninger thank you
alrighty and that's gonna do it for this
edition of the Kaiser report with me max
Kaiser and Stacy Herbert want to thank
our guest Karl denature of market -
ticker dot-org
if you want to catch us on twitter it's
Kaiser report until next time bye y'all
[Music]